cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
we have this tweet from Brian krasis
Marshall mcluhan was the guy sorry Tim
keep going we have this tweet from Brian
krasenstein he says I see a lot of
people claiming that the media and the
establishment habitat for Russell Brand
and that's why these allegations came
out do you know which what's more likely
now I'm going to pause here because the
allegations he's making are both the
same allegation that Russell Brand knew
he did bad things and created an
audience that would challenge the
establishment
and then he says or did he do the same I
think he made a mistake in this one but
I want to play this video that he posted
this is the most insane conspiracy
theory and it it's I it actually makes
me think this is a quote unquote Matrix
attack against Russell Brand let me play
the clip for you boss he's known
since me too started that there are
women out there who have stuff on him
and that it's only a matter of time
before they come forward and expose him
for what he is he's not an idiot
he has known that this day was coming
and so he's had the incentive over the
last few years to cultivate a following
of people who distrust the media who
think that the media are out to get
Russell Brand and that they'll do
anything that they can to do that
and that's what he's been doing since me
too started that's the only way that he
avoids being canceled that's the only
way that this guy with the God complex
stays relevant is if he cultivates this
following of people who will disbelieve
anything the media put out about him
because they'd all trust the media he
has everything to gain from doing now
and that's exactly what he's done
successfully yeah I think it's really
funny that this is the conspiracy theory
that Liberals are going with because
Russell Brand was at Occupy Wall Street
when did metoo start you know he's 17
2017. okay yeah Russell Brand has always
been been political he went to numerous
occupy events he's consistently spoke
spoken up about these things but I love
this conspiracy that 15 years ago he's
like you know one of these days they're
going to come after me for all the
horrible things I've done I better start
cultivating a bunch of conspiracy
theorists who will think that the the
media is lying about me
Mastermind he's like he knew he knew 15
years ago that me too is coming
apparently she didn't warn anybody so he
went to occupy to start spreading the
word and then people would like him and
then he felt like this is the craziest
thing honestly I wish it were true
because that would be even funnier in
some way but he had this crazy long-term
vision for like first I've got to make
some terrible choice in my life but I
will protect myself by cultivating a
podcast like it's crazy I'm being like
in 10 years I'll start a podcast that
cultivates anti-establishment fans but
for now I must go to Occupy Wall Street
to start them off yeah you saw him he's
got like the craziest whiteboard
timeline of all time machine he's got a
Megamind Dome correction it was up there
2006 that uh me too was coined by Tarana
Burke an advocate for in uh for women in
New York yes 2017 that it went viral
nobody knew what it was until Russell
Brandon like 2013 started something
called the trues do you remember that
whereas like instead of the news it was
the truth he got woken up early on red
pill he's all about we don't need
Russell Brand's story to not trust the
media
yeah that's the media it's like I lots
of news at this point and I'm looking at
when I watch Like CNN I can like tell
their federal agents I'm like yeah I
wonder when they graduated from there is
it because the Chiron says former CIA
director when they talk right or even
even the girl that's trying to just be
there like I'm like
these these uh these uh Intel uh
officials and and an analysts and
everything get jobs at the corporate
press and and the Chiron says like
former CIA and they're there in these
roles it's not even it's not it's not
even a joke it's just like yes how was
your mind control course when you're at
the FBI it's going great I'm doing it
right now you know what's messed up
about these allegations though is that
when they when you get when they get the
get you on this you can't defend
yourself you're now you're you're in an
investigation you can't say anything to
defend yourself so now they could just
drag your name through the mud for
however long it takes and this is what
you were talking about earlier like how
do we fix this because
now your whole Legacy is tarnished
because you can't say anything about
you know you're out you gotta win a
culture War yeah because if you say no I
didn't then you're acknowledging the
premise of the accusation yeah your
lawyer tells you not to say nothing you
know the culture that's why I like that
like he put on a statement being like
none of this is true right like there
are so many people who try to like put
their head in the sand be like it's not
happening or like you know I'm so sorry
that you guys feel like maybe I did
something wrong in the past like just
being like no none of this is real is
more interesting it's also more true to
character for Russell Brand I think as
much as you know a lot of people in this
room know already not to trust the media
when he went on Bill Maher and I think
it was in March that clip him saying all
these things you know as many people who
are like oh my gosh good point there are
just as many people being like yes thank
you for saying this on a national
platform like they're pretending like he
came up with this idea of uh uniting
people who don't trust the media people
who don't trust the media find each
other all the time Gilmore I was trying
to cut him off so hard too he's like
okay that's enough right don't say it
don't say bad things about Pfizer oh
what awful companies I love that clip
where it's like today's broadcast is
brought to you by Pfizer brought to you
buy Pfizer brought to you by Pfizer it's
like every single Media company and
that's the way it goes man and that's
why uh you know we
for the most part don't have a lot of
sponsors for this show we do on the
podcast audio side of things and it's
because like I don't want to be put in
these positions there's a reality that
someone might come to us and be like hey
you know we sell this product and then
we'll be like oh sounds totally cool
then we'll do ads and then we'll get
emails be like hey did you know this
product's actually bad because they do
these things to their employees and it's
like okay what do we do they've paid us
it's a conflict of interest do we drop
them that's like cancel culture how do
we investigate something like that it's
like oof that stuff's rough yeah I don't
want to tell people we're not going to
shout out their companies because we
have that fear though but there is the
the other side of predominantly why I
wouldn't want to go with a major
corporation is because like dude I
assume if you're at a certain size
you're probably just evil you know like
and any massive like Starbucks look I
like Starbucks right heavy they're one
of the only coffee shops with heavy
cream you want to get coffee and you're
walking down the city but I'm just
convinced they're evil oh yeah I think
they're poisoning everyone when you
start really looking into the health uh
be be be very afraid of of what you eat
if you're not eating all grass-fed
organic we're all everything has got to
be like absolutely untainted Starbucks
is Tainted definitely you could taste it
if you really just stop and listen to
your body you could feel the poison yeah
what are the ingredients
um it says the ingredients are brewed
Starbucks trademark coffee water coffee
reduced fat milk sugar cocoa pectin
that's it 15 of that company is owned by
BlackRock but the question is when it
says sugar is it high fructose corn
syrup or is it like cane sugar either
way Sugar's bad does it say it on one's
real name
but typically they specify right yeah
the secret that you learn in the
holistic natural medicine world is when
it says natural flavors they are legally
allowed to put whatever they want under
that yeah that there's no regulations
raspberry flavored comes from Beaver ass
yeah or something like that don't trust
anything that says natural flavors
beaver anal glands they're it's called
um look it up you know what I actually
somewhere I think that's actually true I
don't
oh God it's just so disgusting to read
about it it hasn't even gotten to the
food part yet in food
um
flavor schnapps commonly yeah variety of
schnapps doesn't really say
what specific flavor it is
vanilla have you ever seen a beaver
swimming no I said vanilla underwater Oh
yeah you have vanilla they're like
awesome swimmers and I was fishing the
other day and it was just flying
that's awesome this is vanilla I thought
it was uh like raspberry it says uh the
FDA regards because storm has natural
flavoring just in time for the holiday
cookie season we discovered that vanilla
flavoring your baked goods come from
anal excretions of beavers it was also
considered to be used in the cigarettes
to increase the the smell the flavor and
the odor wow little did you know have
you ever seen the videos of the pink
slime
when did you guys get invested in this
um I've been so I'm an athlete I've been
playing uh Sports my whole life but
lately I've been trying to biohack you
know I feel like I'm I'm in a place
where I want to see I want to see what I
can do I want to see what I'm capable of
is you know in in this in this body I
have so I've been working on bio hacking
I've been you know micronutrients uh
everything I put in my body at this
point is really thought out I wake up I
I do I do the sauna I cold plunge I whim
hop breathe I ground I do I do any form
of of biohacking for health and I want
to see I noticed the difference in my
life I noticed my focus I notice I play
sports at a higher level I notice a lot
of benefits of it so I've been really
doing that for the past year hard but my
whole life I've been involved in in you
know trying to eat right and I mean not
when I was 12 right when I'm 12 I'm
eating pizza and french fries that was
the turnaround for me when I learned you
know my mom I love her but she was
feeding us Frosted Flakes and all these
things when you look at this stuff when
you look up with frosted flakes or what
Doritos and what these these foods do to
you they kill us that's it they're
poisons they're chemicals they're
hazardous to our health it's it's it's
crazy that we consume this but we're
we're used to it and do you like
evangelize it to the rest of the band or
how does this work
yeah my wife's a naturopathic doctor
she's been a naturopathic doctor for
like 10 years and when I'm home from
tour like she was doing all her
schooling online and uh so I was just
soaking in all the information so yeah
I've known about seed oils for like
eight years seed oils do you guys go
into stem cells and uh like stem cell
therapy or NAD I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
I do NAD and I'm gonna do stem cell
therapy in January on on my knee where
are you going you go to Tijuana CPI I'm
gonna go to Mexico
cellular performance I haven't picked
that out yet but I'm already going to
Mexico City for something else so I was
gonna just that go to Cellular
performance states where we went and
it's uh Eddie Bravo shot him out on Joe
Rogan those guys are awesome and it's
I'm gonna go bro you you sit in a chair
looking at the ocean and there's
Dolphins like it's so I want to do it so
Rick would you like genetically alter
yourself to be healthier like like
straight up crispr Tech no nope it's got
to be from God or it's got to be for
something that that is natural I'm the
more the older I get the more I learn
everything that we need is on this Earth
to heal ourselves everything the Earth
heals us God has put every single thing
we need here to heal us if you don't
have a cold plunge you could you could
get a cold shower you could you could
stand out in the rain if you're in an
area like this right there's there's
ways to be re-energized the sun well
everything we need is here I heard a lot
about cold lunch a lot about putting
your head under so if you don't have a
full tank just get like a big bowl put
ice in it and then submerge your head
for like 20 seconds thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time